at FIFA 17 they showed a bunch of that
as well to a crab in London who
presumably doesn't really care all that
much about football the euros were
literally on the Germany Ukraine game
was on I was finishing as FIFA was was
on so they showed off single-player
stuff you can never tell if he fuh you
know we have a clown that opening
monologue for a minute but that was
unusual oh it's the Josie morenia thing
oh no this hunter yeah oh my god that's
like this miss without these yours yeah
duh yeah but it was sort of a knowledge
tonal shift from the rest of the noel is
an actor on the stage yeah Wow yeah they
show that off I mean the FIFA the
journey stuff we don't know how it ends
up will it be good like the finite
Chavez stuff will be not so good like
the 2k16 and stuff I don't know well
after what off the wing see at least
they're trying something new I mean it
yeah FIFA's yeah that's interesting but
the first time they've added something
this large into the package in a bed two
or three years well off to wait and see
yeah they'd Arsene Wenger and Jurgen
Klopp on the screen and then Josie
Mourinho came out and chatted for a bit
they showed another trailer and then we
were into EA originals zoink for
Gothenburg okay not fair this is exactly
what they were talking about it did you
call the battery what EA does and I
think it's awesome and I'm glad that
they want to do it as a whole thing as
well mike is and obviously they're
recognizing they know they do that and
it's like well I mean Lily you want to
make a big deal out of it showed one
yeah
yeah don't want me think of thing oh
he's adorable it looks like re okay
blind parts like re it looks a little
bit like tear away um from the urchins
yeah from the concept I thought it
looked a little bit ly limbo but
obviously now seeing it in action it's
it's obviously purple and not like am I
I feel like I've played this game about
six times over the past two years the
TRACON yeah kind of I feel like we're
really getting to the bottom of the well
of these adorable little critters yeah
pinging platformer thing see I yeah I'm
yet to get sick of that all right okay
I'm just cynical when it comes to those
carry these dudes the big towering guys
are right obviously the lovely the
things from Rico the foes yeah they're
kind of creeping me out so they go
that's fair yeah it was interesting they
named game we've seen today for sure